[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey how's it going everyone I'm hey Zeus
here's toes the blood god of blood-borne
and we're here for play for all doing a
charity stream today I am joined you
can't see them but they're here by Jake
and two more from GameSpot how's it
going guys it's going very well thank
you so much for having us on it's an
honor to be on a stream with physics the
blood good or no problem I'm glad to be
here we are going to do a biryeo blade
run in Mac's new game today that's new
game plus six although I've done about
hundreds of them so it's gonna be higher
than that this is the highest level of
difficulty
the bosses are gonna have the most
amount of health and I'm going to take
the most amount of damage we're looking
pretty cool we have our biryeo blade and
we're going to start the run as soon as
this cuts oh wait I got it I got a start
end the game my bad hold on I forgot to
do this one quick second we're gonna
skip this free forget it I didn't
actually sacrifice myself I would never
do that I'm too good at the game
everyone's doing well today
one minute and this thing will start
I'm feeling good today I'm ready to go
this game is going to treat me
wonderfully I guarantee it
it is blood-borne after all I'll try not
to die at all today if I do die let's be
clear I'm gonna die on purpose for
entertainment value only do you guys
like how I look I think you look
incredible
ma I'm writing the the bone ash set
right now and a pair of tight pants
because you know we're speedrunning here
we have to be aerodynamic go ahead this
the cheeks squeak exactly exactly
it doesn't constrict movement I guess
not well they've been perfectly custom
tailored to fit me so everything is
going to go smoothly
Wow the wolf is hungry for that booty he
wasn't able to get it though we're gonna
pull this lever the first ladder of the
game is gonna come down and we're gonna
climb up it of course I love ladders if
you guys do not know I'm obsessed with
them mainly because what I thought I am
the ladder God among other things the
sky god the god of gods of Mount Olympus
the blood God of blood-borne the Thunder
God and the future Kai's Oh God as well
I have a lot of titles as only there's
only a few of them though they're the
ones that are relevant today anyway so
right now we're gonna go to the dream
for the first time you actually have to
go to the dream more than once to
initiate the doll and all leveling we're
going to get the hunter chief emblem
which is going to allow us to get to
vicar Amelia a little bit earlier I'm
doing a little bit of a different route
since I have blood echoes at my disposal
and this is gonna be different than what
you'd see on a regular start from fresh
new game speedrun I'm gonna try to go
through as fast as possible with like I
said no deaths
unless of course I die on purpose
the first boss we're gonna try to get to
is going to be cleric beast then we're
gonna go backwards and go to gas going
right after him but before we get there
we have to meander all the way past all
these towns folks who want nothing to do
what's up with us they want me to get
out of here so that's exactly what I'm
going to do they're gonna take their
shots but they're gonna miss because I'm
just too damn quick break through these
barrels wrap around the left side and
we're just a minute away from the first
boss of the game not many people realize
that these there are bosses in this game
that are completely optional and that
you do not have to fight the main game
of blood-borne only has a few bosses a
lot of the content in the game is
completely optional which is one of the
things that I like about it the most it
allows you to explore it allows you to
discover and we're about to discover a
great giant beast and I take one swing
and I nearly cut his head off take of
this role
he's staggered and we're going back into
the fight I'm not even using a beast
blood pellet because who needs
I'll use more for later on dodge that
attack dodge that attack let's get back
in there hit him with a couple he hits
me in the face how dare he I didn't want
him to lay his hands upon me he's filthy
he's disgusting he's got giant claws but
there's blood everywhere they don't call
me the blood God for nothing
I get engorged by the blood the more I
see the better I am staggers for days
blood-borne has a limb breaking system
which basically means that if you focus
all of your attacks on one limb over and
over again it'll eventually stagger once
you stagger it you can get extra counter
hit damage the bunny jumps up but he
does not hit me and I don't hit him
whiffs for days as you can see even
though this is Mac's new game and I'm
playing with a fully leveled up
character the damage is very miniscule
if he were to hit me three times in a
row I would be dead we're not gonna let
that happen
that's one hit that's two hits that's
through all but he missed I told you I'm
very good I'm very good at not dying but
I could have taken a death there it
would have been perfect but we'll save
the deaths for entertainment purposes
later on now we're gonna go backwards
the way we came and go to the second
boss of the game now that boss that we
just fought cleric beast was 100%
completely optional but the next boss
that we're gonna face is not optional at
all gasps coin and a little known fact
about this boss that we're going to face
is that most people who have played the
game have not defeated this boss only 48
percent of people who played the game
have killed gas war
40 48 percent most people try them and
unfortunately they do not succeed before
we get to him though we're gonna do
what's called sewer skip which is one of
the hardest if not the hardest skips in
the game and I nail it
first try what do you expect thanks guys
that skip I'm not going to lie is
literally the hardest one in the game
normally I use it with a saw Claver but
I still got it with the bird over there
you have to have a perfect perfect angle
of attack and plunge onto the fence at
the exact right moment or you will not
get it you'll roll off and die but we're
not here to die the man of the hour
gasps coy he seems like a normal human
being at least for a little bit but wait
until you see what happens when we make
him a little bit mad he hits like a
truck but my hits are stronger the great
thing about the charge are two in the
biryeo voice is it actually decimates
the most humanoid enemies a full charge
that's not gonna hit we whipped a full
charge we'll get them to back away and
get staggered completely he's smelling
the blood he likes the scent of it it
seems to me it sings to him and it sings
to me much but I hit him with a booty
slap giving him a lesson in proctology
and I'm gonna back away and let him do
his thing
he's gonna explode turn into a giant
beast and immediately pummel me with his
fists he's going for a frenzied hit if
you get stuck in that combo at this
level you will die he jumps I jump no
big deal let's go for a charge go for a
trick
that's what I mean we could die and we
did oh my god he kicked me in the face
and we got absolutely wrecked I knew
that something bad would happen I was
calling for it and it happened now
remember that was 100% on purpose I
would never die in this game without it
without me allowing it to happen I said
I would die and then I did that's how
you know that's how you know let's go so
very entertaining is all right to it
just let us know when we're left you can
shout out donations right now as we get
running back to gas cool awesome so for
those folks watching games for is
raising money for black lives matter so
you can see the bitly link at the bottom
bit Doyle why forge last year's - bail
them and please donate generously if you
can we're also raising money for Co vid
relief efforts you can see the bitly for
that there as well
mental ly for 30s kovat those are two
different charities that the black lives
element of it was added very recently
because we wanted to show our support
for that but just be mindful of where
your and donating I mean either helps of
going to great causes so please donate
generously
we had a $50 donation from Rhonda Merrin
which is very much appreciated thank you
so much thank you from Nick Brown and a
hundred dollars dudes thank you guys so
much for donating it's a huge huge deal
for me to be on here supporting black
lives matter and covert relief it's a
crazy world out there and that's why
this game is is really important to me
because this game is as crazy as
possible basically everything has
unraveled the world has turned out and
not the way that we want it or expect it
that's why it's all the more important
to shape the world in the way that we
want it to be
I decided not to go through the sewer
skip again because those dogs were
attacking me the first time you pass
them there's only one attacking you but
after that multiple cages open up and
it's kind of hard to get on to that skip
and if you do get it the dogs are more
likely to push you off and we don't want
that so we're just going the long way a
little bit and we'll be right back there
in about 30 seconds we just got a pass
by these these angry villagers and he's
gonna light the fireball okay it took
him a little longer today he's slow it's
alright I'll be faster this time let's
use the beasts blood pellet let's power
up ourselves make sure that we can get
through this fight we don't want to die
two times in a row nearly and we get
smacked in the face I plan that to
happen I knew was gonna happen
perfect timing we're gonna bring him
over here get our blood echoes which
mean absolutely nothing and bait him out
again
now the bad thing about these blood
pellets they do scale your damage for
the positive and your favourite but they
make it so that you take more damage as
you can see we've already riled him up
past second phase but his hits are gonna
be even more effective he transforms we
go for a charge he sneaks on by
trades I will heal just in case he goes
for the kill shot for the second time in
a row
he tried hitting me with his foot but
it's no match for me right now second
boss is done we don't want to die again
now we're opening the gate nice quick
shot - Madeline Flores we've donated
$4,000 to black lives matter
Oh thousand dollars are you kidding me
if you so much thank you Madeline that's
unreal at least if did a hundred dollars
the same day Vicent - twenty-five Andrew
sayers did 25 Justin McNeill 25 Michael
shop 200 Emily binstock 225 Madeline
Roberts 25 again and Erik's Fox 100
thank you so much regardless of your
amount is massively helpful that was an
unbelievable amount donated in so little
time thank you so much you guys are
absolutely amazing I can't believe
you've gotten that we've gotten that
much donated already at the start of the
stream that's insane that's so much
money thank you guys so much you saw me
at the beginning of the game go back to
the dream and I purchased the hunter
Chiefs emblem that's what I'm using
right now to open up this gate just a
little bit early we're gonna go this way
instead of going another way because
it'll be a little bit faster on this run
we're gonna use a blue elixir in a few
seconds because you're gonna find that
there's going to be a lot of enemies
once we past this fog we have to climb
up a ladder to get to the next boss
Emilia and we're gonna use a blue elixir
to obscure our appearance you can see
how we're basically semi-transparent
right now this is gonna make it so that
enemies detect us a little bit later
than they normally would and we've
climbed right past them up the ladder
and we're gonna be free to go on our own
now we're up high on the rooftops we got
to drop down
roll forward and climb up these steps
and we were getting closer to the next
boss if you have any other donations it
would be a good time in the next 20
seconds while we're getting there okay
we have Nicole Wilson $25 Brett Cory
born who was banned and unbanned earlier
in your stream his back and he's got a
hundred dollars thank you so much for Co
Joe Ravus salute $25 thank you so much
hi bandit roll in my channel before
while I was streaming although I
accidentally missed click clicked and
hit the only VIP in my channel Greco and
banned him instead you can see he's a
good sport about it that all right we're
gonna go to Amelia hit her with an r1 l1
l1 and get away from there at the
perfect timing she almost smashed me in
a bits but I'm staggering her into
oblivion let's regain some stamina back
away and go back in she smacks me with a
sideways glance and I don't like the way
that she was looking at me so I'm just
gonna spam her she tried to clap me she
tried to grab me but I'm having none of
it
we got her down we're gonna go to her
head and we're gonna take the visceral
dealing massive damage
she's already two-thirds of the way done
I'm hitting her head over and over again
and she just wants to back away you
could tell she doesn't even want to
fight she's mad I'm here she wants this
to be over with as quickly as possible
but she was tricking me the entire time
it was a ruse she was designing to kill
me but you cannot kill what does not die
and I am that which does not die except
when I intended to die to Gascoigne
I was on purpose this boss is done we're
gonna light this lamp and we're gonna
take the long way down so if you got any
more donations you could hit me we do
need you
is absolutely incredible mark Acton $25
deci de coco $25 giulio javonni $100
alejandro and we are no apologies if i
pronounced that wrong $25 Matthew's
sells a $50 to black lives matter thank
you so much
and then $25 from also to Kolb it relief
so much appreciation from our side on
this thank you so much we really really
really appreciate it
you guys are absolutely killing it thank
you for all the donations I cannot thank
you enough now that we are cleared of
the grand cathedral we're making our way
outside of Cathedral Ward we're gonna
pass by this idiot known as old wait he
doesn't even want to show himself today
Alfred he doesn't want to be there so
we're going to the password door once we
killed him Amelia
we got the password for the door which
is fear the old blood we talked to the
guy he's already dead I don't know how
he opened the door but he managed away
now we find ourselves in the forbidden
woods the home place of one of the
hardest bosses in the game it's one
that's gonna stress me out because
basically two or three hits from these
guys is going to kill me
they're up there up in a little bit in a
few minutes here but the truth of the
matter is that they're tough so we're
gonna go back to the dream real quick to
get a full blood vials just in case
something happens just in case something
happens now just a reminder this is new
game plus 6 so everything can kill me
and I mean that absolutely everything
can kill me so that's why I want to have
as many blood vials on my person as
possible and we'll go back to the
forbidden woods and get on with it
so we have one question here from Carol
comb Komarov asking are we doing DLC
bosses - that is definitely the plan I
do not like playing this game without
doing all the bosses we're not gonna do
chalice dungeons or anything like that
but my intention is to go through and do
everything main game everything optional
and everything DLC the DLC is the best
part of the game and ie I don't have it
in my heart to skip it it has the best
bosses still to this day I believe right
over here this is going to be a quick
skip right up these rocks we're gonna
roll through a couple times the floor is
gonna appear out of nowhere and we're
gonna drop down roll through these
barrels and head through the town which
you can see is desecrated they do have a
cannon though our two artilleries never
a bad thing heal action drop down now
you can notice this enemy up ahead is
gonna be a little weird looking he's got
snakes for a head and he's probably
gonna try to shoot them at me
oh he just he just used his arm and then
and then used the snake heads as a
reverberation not too bad he does have
an attack that will one-shot you and
he'd luckily did not give that to me
there that jump that I just did right
there mid jump it was actually making me
slightly worried because I thought that
I had gone just a little bit to the left
if I was literally one more inch to the
left there I would have slid down into a
pocket of grave stones that the player
character cannot escape from the only
thing I would have been able to do would
to be bold hunters mark back to the
beginning of the level and do it again
I'm glad that my ability to jump was not
uh was not compromised there because
that would have been a terrible loss of
time all we have to do is pass by these
morel mushroom looking statues jump down
and run right past this pig that you're
gonna see right off to the right and
we're gonna get to the one of the
hardest bosses
in the game now the thing that makes
these guys more difficult than others is
that there's three of them most of the
bosses in the game are only one on one
but this has three and they hit like a
truck they can hit from a range and it's
gonna be insanely dangerous I use
something to my advantage though it's
called the old Hunter's bone oh my god
we already took a hit now you're gonna
see real quick what this does Oh
actually I misused I didn't use the old
hunters bone I use my vsport pellet
never mind I'll have to show you later
on my mistake if I had not hit that guy
at the right time I would have been
blasted with the fireball and hit with
the uchigatana at the exact same time
that would have been an instant death an
absolute instant death but we're gonna
shoot this guy take the visceral
staggering back is going to give us a
little bit of time to get over here and
slice these guys up oh man that was a
kill shot as well you cannot get stuck
in a flurry with these guys you will die
now if you notice there's two of them
that are exclusively attacking and that
is by design cool just out of range of
that attack which will do about 80% of
my damage
almost died there - I hope you're seeing
a theme here basically the theme is that
blood-borne is trying to kill you at all
times and we're trying to survive
dodging fireballs let's take the
two-shot while they give it to us
roll through all he's stepping back he's
quick all right we have to be careful
here okay so you saw I was trying to
stay in range of that guy if I had gone
back any further he was going to step
back and some three giant snakes that
would have probably killed me does the
probably need to be there no it doesn't
they would have killed me
all right now we're in single hand form
we can rock him unless he escapes my
attack what is that one HP get out of
here shoot him in the head and we're
done you saw he was about to go down in
the ground that was the attack that I
was talking about he was about to summon
those snakes nice thank you any more
donations we do we have a $45 from
autumn key Oh 20 from Vito Antonio 25
from Zachary Brown and reales was
donated $25 Kyle Coleman 25 tree
vaishnav Gaede $100 James Cafferty $100
and then decane blaze 50 dollars towards
Colvin relief res HD $25 and Sarah the
wolf says the blood God commands it $20
thank you so much for every single
donation that we've got so far we're
toning for we're raising money for black
lives matter you can see the bit ly
links for that and the Corbett relief
effort below please do donate generously
and thank you to everyone there has done
so far thank you guys so much you saw in
between the donation readings
I did a little bit of a skip there
that's called the Lunarian key skip and
it allows us to use the elevation change
of that fluorescent flower the tail yeah
I'm sure you didn't notice but the tail
of that that creature was moving and
once it moves into my my eyesight I can
use it to jump off and out of it and
that allows me to go through Bergen
worth went out without actually going
inside the the building so we jump clear
into the water I take out all of those
spiders because quite frankly if they
can still one-shot you even a New Game+
so it behooves us to kill them first now
we're gonna try to stagger rom here
where the charge r2 and we were able to
do it she's trying to teleport away but
we obviously don't want that to happen
we want to do as much damage to her and
phase-one as possible now I'm going to
run directly to her I ran a little bit
past it I was a little overanxious and
I'm dead I'm gonna die there's no way I
could survive this I lied to you you
cannot kill what does not die I thought
that I was going to die
dude what born has it out for me today
blood-borne has it out one more hit
dodge and all the spiders will die now
we should get an instant warp right here
and we do if you know you can tell where
the ROM is going to spawn based off of
the directionality of the moonlight
there so the moonlight casts a
reflection inside the water or on top of
the water which allows me as long as I
pinpoint the moonlight to know where rom
is going to be once you kill ROM the
Blood Moon descends and we head off into
your re-roll one of the most eclectic
and chaotic levels in the game if not in
all of video games this place is wild
with demons Bell maidens who summon up
dead ones and the final boss of the
level is going to be a treat as well
it's basically my entire nemesis any
more donations while we go and get a key
for one of the
becoming optional levels absolutely Alex
Haley who I believe is donated before
donate $100 and thank you so much
Shana note that we are now up to seven
thousand eight hundred and forty eight
dollars for black lives matter and seven
thousand three hundred and ninety one
dollars for covert relief thank you so
much there bit ly links are there we're
donating for to charities at the same
time we want to support black lives
matter and also help have health care
workers but then Coll bit on the front
line so thank you to everyone that has
donated and please if you can donate if
you can't please share the link out to
people and get people in watching Zeus
do his thing and also maybe donate and
thank you thank you guys so much I
really appreciate it
we just got the upper cathedral ward key
and then marked back to the level we are
right now that will allow us to get to
two optional bosses later on in the game
right now we're gonna take out this guy
in a wheelchair so he doesn't shoot us
in the back his friend is gonna come
because it's real angry that we took out
its run which is understandable and we
are going to attempt to skip here we
phase through that fence no problem easy
peasy first try that allows us to skip a
large part of the level get through a
little bit faster I am going to dip
around here I'm gonna go a little bit of
a slower way just cuz it's a little bit
cooler and I'm gonna send the elevator
back up later on because we are gonna
come back here for another boss we're
gonna go kill one reborn and then we're
gonna come back later for darkbeast par
this might be something people have
never seen before it's basically a bath
and when you take a bath you teleport to
another bath I wish most baths were like
van realize I don't know how we can get
this technology but I think we should be
looking into it drop down here take a
back step if you don't back step there
what's gonna happen is you're gonna get
a really long pause and we're a kind of
speed running so we're not gonna do that
now this guy my nemesis the most
eclectic boss ever designed I mean look
at this thing it's giant it's disgusting
and it's ready to kill me we're gonna go
in and hit him a few times get him to
stagger switch to my long scythe and hit
the main body now he's gonna come down
we have to dodge fireballs and corpses
which he is dropping from thin air now
this is the limb brake system on display
right here oh that's an explosion you
have to avoid that and that's a bigger
explosion that needs to be avoided as
well there's the limb it's broken the
main body drops down and we're gonna
take as much damage as we possibly can
dodging fireballs more corpse drops and
he's dead excuse the loud sound it's a
little bit of a sound glitch sometimes
it just is louder than others and I
don't know why we're gonna touch Michael
ashes body and head somewhere else you
guys have any questions or anything a
lot of people are just enjoying your
commentary I'm glad I'm glad I'll keep
going on we're in the lecture hall right
now which is basically a space that is
adrift in the nightmare it separated
itself from reality if that makes sense
but it's not fully in the nightmare it's
kind of like a limbo zone or just
passing through right now
we will come back here later when we
have another boss to kill
actually do have one from Marc Ashley
Jones is that is using the uncanny
burial blade no I'm not using the
uncanny this is just a normal biryeo
blade I do have every weapon in the game
upgraded to +10 but I don't have the
uncanny and lost versions those too if
for people who don't know there are
different versions of the weapons in the
game that you can find in the chalice
dungeons which allow you to slot
different gems and gems are things that
basically upgrade your attack power so
certain gems have certain shapes and
different weapons have different gem
slots and this just allows you to a
min/max your build to your heart's
content
most people don't find their way into
the chalices though but I would
recommend it we got to the lamp just in
time before that silver beasts almost
destroyed us right there right now we're
gonna go back to the dream you saw me a
little bit low on blood vials we are but
we're gonna do something else we're
gonna go back to your horror goal we
have two more bosses to kill before we
go and fight Michael ash the host of the
nightmare the one boss that we skipped
over was dark beast parl who's in Uehara
goal and then after we kill that guy
we're gonna go into old yharnam through
the back way which is a little bit
quicker to fight blood star beast who I
like to call Suzy skin flaps you can
tell by the reaction that they
immediately have realized why I call her
Susie skin flaps the reason is very very
simple she has two missions every types
of skin hanging off of her back it's
disgusting but it's also kind of
beautiful in a blood-borne kind of way
but I'll say that again that she kind of
looks like me to be fair our dao you
give yourself more credit you've got a
beautiful beard going on tomorrow don't
think I haven't noticed I've been just
trying to get somewhere close to where
you are somewhere anywhere just in the
vicinity
at stake it's taken me a long time to
get my beard to where it is for those of
you who don't know I actually am
literally a beard the beard is me I was
born a beard what happens is the beard
latches on to a human host with the chin
I grow through the chin into the brain
and outside the other side basically
this allows me to sort of like floss my
brain I'll show it off real quick so if
you pull on the beard the hair goes up
pull on the hair the hair goes down you
see how that works it allows you to
Frosch floss your brain which is really
really nice it gets you thinking some
clear thoughts and honestly I wouldn't
be the person I am without that we're
gonna take a hit here
that explosion will get anyone now this
boss is tough I'm not gonna lie I've got
a focus on this guy
he swiped me twice right off the bat
he's going for the electric attacks
immediately this is rare usually he
takes some time to warm up to it but he
is having none of it he I've already
killed him once today and he is mad you
can tell darkbeast Paul is no joke and
later new game no joke when one of the
most difficult bosses in the game I
think mainly because the camera is an
insane issue now that's a perfect die
frame right there a really really hard
oh my god my weapon is at risk
that means I'm doing less than half the
damage who's who starts up a charity run
for GameSpot but forgets to repair their
weapon hey Zeus does that's who it's
honestly kind of embarrassing but you
know what we're gonna make it through
anyway it doesn't matter
weapon at risk weapon broken it means
nothing to me I'm killing Carl all the
same you could jump on me
you could try to swipe me with your
lightning attacks but quite frankly
trying to kill a god of thunder with
lightning doesn't exactly make too much
sense now does it it's almost like a
prebuilt in anti defense mechanism for
light now he's lost his ability because
I've talked some tents into him oh but
he brings it back right after you see
what is proof that blood-borne is
listening to my every word it is
conscious a I never I mean never connect
was born to an artificial intelligence
system it will take over the world
now as soon as I get my bearings I've
never been that far over there when I
fight that guy I've got to go back to
the dream to repair my weapon here so
hit us with a few more donations
absolutely $25 from Michael sharp this
is all for black lives matter
Alexander hull gold 25 donations Matteo
marishi $10 Rebekah certain $25 Lindsay
Johannes $100 my calls and Torah $100
odd for Roskam 25 Brianna Bart Brian
Harrison $100 Gustavo's Sinofsky $25 Leo
Ward $25 and then we have suckers $20
for covet relief and then Gustavo $20
for Kobe relief saying the blood God
demands it
both donation links are below I just
want to shout out the chat on your
channel the community that's following
hey Zeus you watching the chair and
they've been incredibly wholesome and
really positive thank you so much
same for the folks on the GameSpot chat
and a lot of good vibes in there please
do share and donate generously my
community knows that there are
representation of me and I refuse to
allow people in my community who
wouldn't be a good representation of all
of my ideals so you're gonna find that
the guys who are donating the guys who
are participating in chat are just
basically stand up as possible thank you
guys for being the way you are thank you
we got another question here from DTS KP
what Zeus's favorite weapon in the game
my favorite weapon in the game is going
to pend depend on the the day that you
asked me there's so many good weapons in
this game I love the Aptus all cleaver
is a great one the blood letter the
church pick is amazing the ligarius real
the Koz parasites literally allows you
to lick enemies to death is it so hard
to choose any one the whirligigs saws
some of the most fun
in a video game I loved blood-borne
because there's just so much variety in
this game and here you can see Suzy skin
flaps those big dangly things right off
of her back are in fact flaps of skin I
don't know how they got there I don't
know why they're still there I wish you
would take them off but Who am I to tell
her what to do with her life she almost
killed me for saying that so you know
what I'm gonna be a little bit more
respectful of her personal choices get
around the right side and hit her with a
booty slap take a visceral attack and go
right back into it smack her face off
over the immediate charge if I was smart
I would have been right behind her ready
for that let's go for a full charge and
we knock her down I didn't think it
would knock her down that far I thought
that only applied to hunters but
apparently we can knock down giant
beasts as well rolling through that
attack and we're getting whips my beast
blood pellet has run out here we got to
dodge that that is a one shot no matter
what happens I saw she was doing it I
saw she smelled me in the air and she
was looking for a kill but Spiker while
she's transforming there's a one shot
again you cannot get grabbed by this
boss now you notice that there's a big
giant poison cloud
coming out of her body now if I stand
too close to her I will get poisoned
very quickly so I have to be at the
exact right distance while I'm attacking
or I'll build up too much poison too
quickly
there's the one-shot attack again you
cannot get grabbed can I get into a
flurry let's go for a jump slapped her
down she's not dead let's look away and
get a damn parry oh I couldn't get the
visceral I killed her but that was
pretty good let's go to butch cheeks are
clenched the entire time here now see I
could fight these bosses in a different
way I could fight them like say with no
hit strats and be a little less
aggressive but one of the things that I
love about blood-borne is that I can
take advantage of getting hit and I
could be aggressive with enemies and go
back and hit them immediately after they
hit me and as long as I don't get hit
again I won't die I love that system in
the game because it just really just
allows you to be aggressive keep the
combat up and never stop and that's how
I like to play games I like to be right
I like to heal right in a boss's face
the disrespect I want to show them the
disrespect any more donations we're in a
new area we got to take a little bit of
a trick to the next boss we have Michael
sharp they're gonna hit $100 for black
lives matter
Dwayne Dame ler I hope that promise all
right $25 and then someone called
individuals towards $50 thank you so
much both links to donate are at the
bottom pit doorway for slash either
Jesus - BLM for black lives matter or GS
- covert for Kobe relief going
health care workers please donate if you
can't you can't share the screen get
people watching Zeus just play through
and get him in the chat get him some
support too as well
good vibes all around I almost died it
at a silver piece right there there's
when you're opening a door in this game
you have iframes so even if something is
iframes are invincibility frames they
mean that no matter if an enemy comes
into contact you you won't get damaged
so when you're opening a door enemies
can't do damage to you but the moment
after you open the door they can and
there's there's a perfect moment in time
where they can actually attack you at
just the right moment so you cannot
respond and like I said I would have
died there and had to come back all
again but luckily he was a little bit
nicer than that there's an elevator up
to the left we've got to be very careful
here dodge the act and then quickly go
into the the elevator here because
there's a guy with a crossbow that you
can see off stream or off screen and and
he will wreck you pass by some crow dogs
those are crow bodies with dog heads in
them I will be taking this shortcut just
in case me coal ash if you guys have not
fought me coal ash I'm sure a lot of you
have you know he can punch you you know
he can spam you with noodles and you
know he can cast a magic attack called
the call beyond now imagine him on Mac's
new game with all those abilities he's
swifty he's scurvy and he hits like a
literal truck pretty much any attack
from him that is magic arcane will kill
me so I have to be very careful with my
with my strategy here because I cannot
get hit we are gonna take out this
puppet here so he doesn't come backwards
and kill me
we're gonna draw them into this little
vestibule and hit him with an r1 r1 r1
r1
r1 r1 r1 you see how complicated is this
not many people can do this we're gonna
hit him with an r1 r1 r1 r1 r1 r1 r1 r1
like I said very very difficult do the
same thing again he almost killed me
I took I forced out the the it's called
auger of every ettus yes yes the auger
is very majestic Michael ash I forced
him out did a little stutter step so he
wouldn't hit me it was little a little
too close though I didn't want it to be
that close not gonna lie if out he was
gonna die in one less hit but
blood-borne is great with given enemies
a sliver of health when you're least
expecting it I'm pretty sure the game is
100% designed to give you health slivers
so Michael ash in this game is in a game
where you are a hunter going for prey
he's one of the few he's one of the few
pieces of prey that actually runs away
from you and he ran at the right time
are you kidding me he shoved the gate on
me at the last second I can't believe he
did that so now we got a run all the way
back up to the top this guy has it out
for me I can tell what he's planning
this is actually really really dangerous
I'm gonna get full health I've got a
drop and plunge down here I don't want
to you shut up I got to turn around and
hit him right on his head at the right
time let's go now I can't I can't oh he
back stepped an iframe that attack man I
got to get him into a corner let's do
that he I framed it again this guy is a
legend
no no he almost killed me that was
definite death definite death and we
gotta we got him that fight is always
sketchy as hell fantastic we've got two
more questions here first ones from Lucy
James how did you find Sakura's combat
compared to blood-borne oh I love
Secretary's comments like in blood-borne
you hit you parry things every once in a
while but in second oh the entire combat
is based around parrying pretty much
every attack and the precision that you
get from that or the precision that the
game requires is just beautiful I want
these games to be harder I want them to
be more difficult I've been playing them
since since demon souls in 2009 I I
loved second oh I really did the combat
system was absolutely amazing what's the
other question the next one here is what
Zeus is favorite boss fight this one's
from Rendy pitama hopefully I pronounced
that right my favorite boss fight that
is an absolute easy question it's orphan
of cause in all of the from software
games it's still my favorite I still
think he's the hardest and by hardest I
mean that even when you're good at the
game like oh if you if you consider all
the best blood-borne players they don't
they all seem to die to orphan of cause
every once in a while including myself
and the reason is because he's so damned
aggressive and he constantly comes up
with new ways to kill you as well and
you mix that with his weapon his model
the arena the music the cutscene you get
before and after all the lore
surrounding him I absolutely love that
boss fight it's like no other for me you
prefer the all one button or the auto
button
I prefer the l1 button the l1 is my
favorite because the l1 does all those
cool attacks that allow you to switch
the form of your weapon while you are
attacking say you you you switch from
short you switch from long and and some
of the weapons have just absolutely
awesome attacks and that's why I like to
show off the biryeo blade because I
think this weapons moveset is just
absolutely sick this is gonna kill me if
I wasn't good at dodging cool man
okay wet-nurse is being a little bit of
a troll to me right now but I'm gonna
buckle down and get her I also have no
more beef blood pellets I've got to
remember oh my god I staggered her at
the exact last second possible she was
about to slice me in half right there
let's get behind her
oh just miss just miss
usually the biryeo blade will give me a
good amount of range but right there the
range has failed me
biryeo blades also one of the few
weapons that hasn't a standard l2 attack
and that's it right there it actually
has a full l2 combo which is one of the
things that I love about this weapon
there's so many different ways of
playing blood-borne cool
so that was nightmare phase if you guys
have ever seen that a blade basically
the entire room turns black and she
spawns a copy of herself but I'm able to
dodge a nightmare phase by locking on to
her and dashing twice as soon as the
purple orb appears and that's what I did
there to stop that from happening any
more donations absolutely $25.00 from
Vincent Kelly 25 dollars from our very
own Renault 4 MZ Morgan Sinclair
donate $10 Sebastian Ramsey donate $25
that's all for black lives matter and
then we have on the covered relief side
we have lunar bound $35 and diamond Tom
berry $20 who says keep up the good work
zoos praise the blood god thank you so
much for the donations both bit ly links
are down in at the bottom the video if
you're in deuces chat you'll see someone
is clearly and very kindly put links in
for that and donate if you can if you
can't please spread our links and tweet
out the actual video we've still got the
wall left here and it's a lot of fun and
so spread the word thank you so much
we're about to go back to the the
lecture hall which is that place that's
askew or a drift in the nightmare
and we've got to go down this way we're
gonna attempt a little bit of a skip
here oh we nearly hit it first try we
nearly hit it second try ah man this
this this skip is called I call it luck
sure hall skip because it is based on
skill but sometimes you get that jump
but it doesn't actually push you over
and it takes a little while to get some
time yet the game is not being nice how
the game is being a jerk by this point
it's actually faster to go the other way
or try it a few more times
oh come on video game I want to show it
off yeah it's giving me the jump but
it's not getting me over there there we
go
took a few times that would probably
lost me 20 seconds on a speed run but
we're not doing a full speed run right
now so I'm not gonna get angry I have
the tendency of getting very angry when
I fail skips but we're not gonna do that
today we're having fun so speaking of
which DTS KBS what was the most
difficult thing to learn for
speedrunning blood-borne orphan of cause
that fight are getting that fight
consistent is absolutely the hardest
thing I actually came up with a strat
called orphan bait where basically you
can use an animation or something like
healing to to bait him to do a couple
different attacks which are much more
easily backstabber ville and so what
that does is if you time orphan baits at
the the exact right time are you
basically can make it so his
transformation happens a little bit
later than normal and you want to fight
him in first phase as long as possible
this that I just did right here is
another skip we're trying to control
everything
that's what we're doing right here I
think I should have gotten it we're only
gonna know as soon as we login we got to
make sure we're going in the right
direction because you can actually get
stuck inside the rocks here let's see if
we did it
we did nice nice
thank you two more right up there you
can see that's where we're going
that Leaning Tower of Pisa looking
building there's actually a creature
called anomic dollar they're an anomic
dolla is basically a giant mushroom if
you've ever look up morel mushrooms mo
re L and tell me this thing is an amoral
mushroom let's come to life
all right
for some reason I didn't get a lot of
damage on that headshot there I'm not
sure why it just registered it's
basically nothing no big deal we'll have
to make do as you can see this monster
is absolutely a giant it has sprawling
limbs and we're gonna try to spam and
stagger the limbs just like we do with
most other bosses but it's very it's
very hard to get consistent hits one
cool thing about the combat system in
blood-borne is that you can use the
camera to alter the angle and the
directionality of your attacks so you'll
see me looking up that's for a very
specific reason if I do not look up I
will not hit and we hit her right in the
face
and we're gonna take an awesome look and
vicinal the animations in this game are
unparalleled this game was made 5 years
ago and I still think nobody has beaten
in terms of animation work every boss
has different death animations oh that's
dangerous
that's really dangerous we're getting
out of there
different death animations depending on
how you kill them so if you kill them
with a visceral attack versus killing
them with a basic attack or a backstab
the animation will be different which i
think is just amazing
you can see she's going on a frenzy here
I'm taking as many head shots as I can
because she is weakened mad and she's
probably gonna rip off her arms now she
died
we're gonna go for crotch shots now
she's stepping up go for a head shot go
right back underneath in between her
legs gotta be careful got to be careful
do not get hit with that one more crotch
shot and another one for the kill very
tough fight nice bangs let's go back to
the dream hit me with a few more
donations so we have sebastian ramsey
who we mentioned earlier $25 is watching
and enjoying the stream very much so hi
Sebastian and then we have $100 from our
very own Lucy James thank you so much
hello blood-borne fan and 100 for a
donation there yeah that's over now
thank you to everyone who is donating
both links are at the bottom of the
video you can hit up any of those links
to either donate to black lives matter
or to Cove 8:19 relief we have past
$8,000 on black lives matter with eight
thousand six hundred and sixty eight and
on COBE relief for at seven thousand
four hundred eighty six thank you so
much for your donations is gonna be
massively helpful that's an insane
amount of money already I can't believe
it thank you guys so much now I've
decided to do something I'm gonna try
this real quick this is the worst thing
to ever happen a blood-borne
speedrunning right here but I'm gonna
try it right now basically if I can get
it within two minutes oh my dad don't
get it there if I can get with it in two
minutes it'll be faster than going
around though the long way
so I'm trying I'm trying to get this
wolf to grab me at a certain certain
time at a certain place and the reason
that I'm doing that is because like I
said it'll be faster I'm trying to get
him to push me through that gate ah but
he doesn't want to do that he doesn't
want to do that right
at all you see how it was you see what
he does this wolf is actually programmed
to do nothing I mean that seriously
there's a 20 percent chance that this
wolf just looks at you and scurries look
at him apparently in the Japanese code
in the Japanese code it says that the
player will have to be very lucky for
that to happen but I'm I'm basically the
luckiest person on the planet cuz he
does it for me all the time
we got the skip though we pee pushed me
through and this allows us to access
forbidden woods a lot earlier than we
should be able to you can do that skip
at the first part of the game and you're
gonna see that the the back way
oh wait I'm going the wrong way I just
wanted to show you guys I literally go
in the wrong way I just wanted to show
you guys these long hard wooden ladders
I mean they're there twin ladders here
that are absolutely amazing examples of
engineering here I mean look at how tall
these things are it's absolutely
gorgeous
it wouldn't be a hay-zu stream if I
didn't call out these beautiful ladders
one for the chunk of spamming that is
great ladder spam it's basically my
lifeblood if if I go a day without
ladder spam I'm just miserable I was
actually in a little bit of a bad mood
before because yesterday there was no
ladder spam in my channel and and I had
a shoe everybody out but today you can
see that they learned their lesson and
things are going much better all we've
got to do is go on to the right here
there's two things we need there's the
cainhurst summons and an umbilical cord
the cainhurst summons is going to allow
us to access an optional level of the
game called cainhurst and do an optional
boss which is absolutely amazing the
umbilical cord is basically going to do
the same thing but the thing is we need
three umbilical cords we need to destroy
three of them to trigger the final boss
of the game so we have to go around and
make sure we get these items so we can
trigger every single boss now the thing
about getting a couple of the umbilical
cords is actually kind of brutal because
we just have to hit this woman who's
this on this table right here take the
umbilical from her and get the hell out
of here like it never happened
hit me with some more donations we have
$25 from Jared Colburn $50 from our own
Chris Pereira and 25 from our own well
Fulton and then $15 from randy retama i
hope that i pronounced that right thank
you so much for joining everyone to win
really appreciate hopefully links below
ones for black labs now the other one is
for kovat relief thank you so much
please share the stream if you can't
donate if you can please do so you start
editor go ahead go ahead our
editor-in-chief son Sebastian has a
question for you how many hours or how
long did it take you to get good at this
game
well see you can always get better so
even by my own by my own definition
right now I wouldn't even classify
myself as good or as good as I could be
because I sort of like have semi retired
from serious serious speedrunning and I
you I used to practice save files every
single day and I don't really do that
anymore I used to believe it or not be a
better player than I am right now but
how long did it take me to get good when
I first started playing blood-borne I
did three weeks or about two and a half
three weeks of save file practice just
on the bosses doing the bosses over and
over and over and over again until I
could beat them consistently and
repeatedly that was about two and a half
to three weeks like I said and once I
started a speedrun after that my first
speedrun was about two hours and a
couple minutes I think it was maybe two
hours five minutes something like that
and then over the course of like the
next year I got it down like 4050
minutes or so beyond that and it just
it's the whole speedrunning and
blood-borne community eventually comes
up with new strats and you always have
to learn new things so it's it's always
a process it's always a process but it
took me about I would say two and a half
three weeks to get decent
the game and then months and months and
months and months to get actually good
and I've lost it you better start
practicing sebastian practice is the key
with anything in life if you don't
practice you're not doing it right now
we're in the upper cathedral ward oh my
god please do not kill me sometimes
these guys just troll you and they
refuse to let you go but we managed to
scrape on by thankfully there are two
bosses in in this area basically the
first one is gonna be kind of a joke I
say that I'm probably going to die
because of that I just jinxed myself
unfortunately but what are you gonna do
this guy up here is blocked in our way
if he points we can get past them oh
never mind
okay okay he can still hit me through
the wall he doesn't though now I
switched to a Kerr camera here just so I
can perform what's called the orphanage
key skip I'm gonna jump hit this brain
sucker through the wall charge charge
again and charge one more time and the
orphanage key as you see right there is
going to magically get teleported
through that door into my pocket so we
don't have to go all the way around the
other side that saves about 45 seconds
just by doing that a very handy little
trick you can also do the the first part
of that stick with the threaded cane so
give it a try if if you've never done
that before
it's it's pretty easy to do this is the
orphanage key this is the door that we
are opening with the key I should say go
around to the left we're gonna make it
quick right let's make sure I have yes I
do have my beasts blood pellets on I'm
gonna switch to the the long hand
version of this weapon the way this boss
fight works is there's one real boss and
then there's a lot of minions that look
exactly like the real one so we're gonna
kill all the minions first because
believe it or not these guys are small
but like everything in New Game+ six
they can kill you quick way too quick
actually
so we're gonna try to get him to go here
we're gonna hit him a few times I'm
gonna hit him one more time he's gonna
transform I'm gonna try to get back him
wow I was just a split second too late
missed the transform opportunity this is
actually dangerous now i jinxed myself
before remember remember I jinx myself
how are we gonna go about this let's see
you know what there's something we could
do
there's something we could do I've been
saving this so let's use it now oh god
just get behind the pillar first let's
get behind the pillar first let's hit
him with the cannon
easy-peasy how is blood-borne not the
best game ever made I mean you literally
can have a cannon strapped to your arm I
love this game I love this game
one more boss to go just down this
elevator is every ettus now every ettus
was probably one of the toughest bosses
for me on the first playthrough not the
toughest but definitely one of them
she's a giant boss and giant bosses are
tricky to get the hang of and she
doesn't exactly have limbs like other
bosses
she has noodles and you're gonna find
that noodles are actually really really
strong weapons so we're gonna attack the
noodles and try to cut them on
I attacked a little bit too much
unfortunately one attack too many means
I staggered her before I was doing any
damage and now the fight is going to be
a lot sketchier because of that
she put her head down which will allow
me to get a head shot or two we want as
many head shots as possible against his
boss under the noodles were sleeping try
to get some head shots if we can get a
stagger that would be keen she's laying
her head down come on one more head and
we got the stagger let's go for the
visceral watch how sick this is and
let's jump and kill sliced her in half
an easy fight now let's go back hit me
with some more donation we have $10 to
black Lesnar from Peter Liana thank you
so much and as girls Mars Vick $25
Alessandra Barbosa very own $25 same for
chastity of Ascencio $25 thank you so
much for your donations everyone links
are at the bottom of the video as you
can tell please hit them up and donate
to call the relief effort money going
straight to health care workers fighting
on the front line against Ovid and then
the other one is for BLM if a black life
matters supporting our brothers and
sisters impacted by systemic racism
thanks so much tomorrow we're going
right into the DLC right now although
I'm going to be upfront with you we're
not doing the DLC bosses right now I
want to get rid of the other optional
content bosses until we go into the DLC
but what we can do is run through pick
up the items that we need to do and then
once we get to the safe lamp right
before Ludwig one of my favorite bosses
I will warp out we'll go take care of
the witch of hemic and then ligarius
right after that so we got a little bit
of running to do if you guys have any
questions for me or anything you want to
say feel free to hit me with them
we've got donation of $100 from Tommy
Cebu photos black red black lives matter
tell me I guess I have a question how
much would you how many hours do you
estimate that you've now played this a
manhole it's getting close to five
thousand hours now still and go the
upper of four thousands but I've pretty
much done everything that you can do in
this game multiple times and I'm not
even exaggerating I've played the game
with every single weapon I've played the
game I've done a dual wielding gun run I
had the world's first no hit run in
blood-borne I've done every single speed
run even speed run categories that don't
exist I've I've sped around the game
from new game to new game plus six in
one sitting
I've done 24 hours of blood-borne I did
I actually just did a run that was
really cool I called it the the hunter
doppelganger run where I I went through
the game and every time I fought every
single hunter in the game with their
outfits and with their weapons and
hunters tools that they used and I did
that for the bosses as well that was one
of the favorite my favorite runs that
I've ever done so that's where a forty
seven forty eight hundred hours will get
you you got to come up with creative
ways to make the game fun and the thing
about blood-borne is that it's it kind
of is easy because there's so much in
this game that you can do that alters
the gameplay that alters the that guy is
never kicked me before what is this this
is what I'm talking about
this game is a mate that guy is never
front kicked me before in my life he
blocked me just front kicked me and he
was like get the hell out of here I love
it
now on a speedrun something like that is
gonna make me incredibly angry but I've
learned to shy away from doing as many
speedruns because this game so enjoyable
when you you stop and smell the roses
over the - moans so this
we have a question from you riot here it
says do you fully understand the more or
they're still parts of this game that
are still very much a mystery
I am a lore master I have a PhD in
blood-borne ology I am the four foremost
authority on everything concerning the
doll is evil don't trust the doll if
you're out there trust me she is evil
I love the lore in this day and I make
it my mission to let the world and
everyone in the world know that they
have been lied to by this seemingly nice
entity that has nothing to gain but her
own whims I said I wasn't gonna do the
dlc but we're here we're doing it
surprise he's now you see I'm focusing
on the same side and we get the stagger
and we're spamming the hits after the
stagger got a head shot but it was able
to roll through he's charging that's a
one shot you gotta gotta get away from
that he smacked me I gotta get away
we got a heal he's going for the
ectoplasm so we're going over to his
other side and we're gonna spam that a
couple times he hit me with his head and
I might die here yeah you see that
I got stuck I knew it as soon as it was
gonna happen that I got stuck in between
the the column right there unfortunately
unfortunately it happens though
sometimes you just get into a bad spot
in a bad position and if you don't
realize it early enough it's just it's
gonna kill you no matter what I didn't
realize I was getting stuck and I tried
to move to the left but I wasn't moving
to the left so that's what happened we
got a run back all the way they say see
that was a total mistake on my part
because I wanted to get that Lam so this
wouldn't happen but I was talking and
what one thing that happens when I talk
is that I forget to worry about what's
happening
the game it's la it's I'm more concerned
with the words coming out of my mouth
and the giant demon that's trying to cut
my head off and I've got a reprieve to
reprioritize my my thoughts there are
sometimes any more donations while we do
a quick run back we do we have $25 from
our very own Matthew Padgett who
recently played the game on a stream
wave Jake and has become obsessed with
it so blood-borne captures another mind
awesome
Bellhorn sha another one of our own
staff members and $25 thank you so much
and we have AP old red for $10 thank you
so much that's for black lives matter
and then on for conveyed relief we have
new or
so tip $20 says blood for the blood god
keep being awesome Zeus thank you so
much to everyone that has donated huge
shout out to the community in Zeus chat
everyone's being super super supportive
and a lot of newcomers to the stream are
being welcomed very warmly thank you so
much and everyone in the games watcher
who is joining in and having a great
time with us thank you so much you guys
are being absolutely awesome thank you
so much let's get this blue alert is it
gonna go out is it gonna go out it does
go out okay I knew it was gonna go out
hold on this is a very sketchy area here
don't kill me
if he hits me one more time I'm dead
luckily we're not who I I wasn't kidding
when I said it you could die around
every corner in this game especially on
max new game especially on Max's new
game now we're gonna go right instead of
left and get the lamp so if we die we
don't have to do this
I did have a plan like I said and I
didn't stick to the plan and it cost me
some time if you make a plan you got to
stick to it I always do that to myself I
have I I set out a course and halfway
through I'm just like yeah we'll just
we'll just do it we'll just do it this
way and it never works out that way it
never works out so we're gonna go back
how many let's get some more beast blood
pallets real quick just for later and
we're gonna go to which of heme wick and
ligarius so we need to go to the grand
Cathedral for that one the the which of
heme wick lies some people don't find
hemic on the first playthrough it's it's
right to the right of the grand
Cathedral and it's it's kind of really
easy to miss even though it's just right
there but it's one of my favorite areas
in the game it's it's haunting it's
harrowing the boss at the end of it I'm
not gonna lie to you isn't one of the
the best bosses in the game it's one of
those mechanic bosses probably one of
the easier ones however excuse me on New
Game+ six she becomes a little bit more
difficult because they have these grab
attacks that lock you in place and she
summons entities called mad ones
which what happens is she'll lock you in
two or three mad ones will come over
spam you with devastating attacks and
then the other which will appear out of
nowhere and just give you this explosion
arcane attack that'll just destroy all
of your health so it's rare for that to
happen but it is something that can
happen so you got to be careful
especially since the fight takes a lot
longer then most people are accustomed
to on on regular old new game we've got
a meander through all these dogs with
spikes in them it will take a little bit
of a way to get there this bad guy right
there
the guy with the red slaw
that's the mad walk you're gonna see a
lot of them knee in the upcoming boss
fight
hopefully okay so sometimes when you're
at a door enemies can actually put
themselves in front of you while you're
opening it that's what happens right
there it can get pretty dangerous but
luckily we were able to get on through
don't speak too soon all right we're
through kumo got hit though jeez I'm
still getting chased I am still getting
changed that's rare we got this troll up
ahead just roll through while someone up
top throws a MOLLE at you this is
evidence of like good passing this is
what I've learned over the course of
years if you take slight paths
adjustments and go the wrong way
something like that Molly will hit you
in the face give the troll enough time
to turn around and jump at you and very
quickly
leads to a death so it's very important
to know your route and stick to it any
more donations in the next 30 seconds
before we get to the boss
we have 25 dollars from Andrew Freya's
coconuts all right and then 25 dollars
from Dan Christensen and then those are
for black lives matter and then we have
one from Michael's resolve oh I think
that is $25 and he says what a legend a
lot of people in chat and a lot of
people on Twitter are really really
enjoying your commentary in your places
so thank you so much oh that's awesome
glad you guys are enjoying it I love
playing this game even though I play it
so much when I do stuff like this and it
just makes me realize just how great of
a game it is and I'm glad to be one of
those guys that can just teach people
about blood-borne and show it off
because as much recognition as this game
gets I still feel like it deserves even
more I really believe this is the best
game ever made gameplay wise anyway and
then everything else added to it just
makes it even that much better
agreed bori slap we got it we're gonna
take a visceral she's gonna step up and
we're gonna get some more damage on her
all right half way that's actually
really good that's really good now you
see only one boss bar there that was I
wasn't trying to jump there let's do the
same thing booty slap take the visceral
she teleported away there there is only
one boss bar but that doesn't mean
there's only one boss after a certain
part of the fight you'll see another
boss bar appear and you can see that
these witches are invisible until you
are actually very close to them which
makes it really hard to find when where
they are so you end up meandering around
the entire room and this is what I mean
with those mad ones they find perfect
moments to come over to you just to
wreck your day I found her and at just
the right moment she transports away but
luckily I was able to be right there
take that take the visceral now you see
I did no damage to this one no damage
and that's because the boss bar hasn't
appeared yet this one you'll see damage
and we killed it now there's only one
left but the trick here you know I'm
gonna kill this one I don't like its
location oh there's the grab attack
right there can't get hit by that I
gotta get out of here I gotta play it
safe I don't want to die to this and
have to do it again there's the grab
attack again and again
BAM we got it all right now before our
later or now before we picked up the the
cane her summons in the the clinic
remember we're going to take that
summons and come right on down here and
trigger a special cutscene that is going
to allow us to get to a new part of the
game gonna be right here let's go
through any more donations absolutely
the chat says I sound bored so but I'm
not I'm so I'm gonna be a little more
animated with these ones $50 from Erica
M thank you so much and then ten dollars
from corner Brown much appreciated for
those for those donations we are raising
money for black lives matter you can see
the bitly link below and we're also
raising money to support healthcare
workers battling Cove 8:19 relief
efforts the other link for that is also
in the bottom of the video please donate
generously if you can if you can't go
out there and share the stream let's get
more people watching the actual gameplay
that's interesting for us and get more
people interested in blood-borne at the
same time who calls you out for sounding
boring I'll ban looking I'm not gonna
I'm honestly in trance then soothed by
your game play and your commentary this
is what happens you're you're my ASMR so
this is what I sound on anime thanks so
much dude here all those cry oh go ahead
Oh quite a few people in the chat want
to know at least in the GameSpot chat
want to know your thoughts on Elden ring
I thought I want I want it whatever yeah
there's only been there yeah there's
only been the original teaser that they
released which you know looks great look
I'm a Miyazaki fanboy I've literally
been playing these games since 2009 on
Demon Souls I put a few thousand hours
and a demon souls a few thousand hours
and a Dark Souls not as much in a Dark
Souls 2 because I had to get a job at
that point but I love these games and I
cannot wait
for the next game that Miyazaki is
working on and adding george RR martin
to it I think is gonna be really cool
because I think it's gonna bring a lot
of people into the genre that might have
been hesitant beforehand because of the
name that he carries and it'll give him
something to work on besides Game of
Thrones which he clearly doesn't want to
work on anyway but I'm I'm I cannot wait
for elven ring whatever it is I firmly
believe that Miyazaki is an artist and
he should just be making the games that
he wants to make and I just want to play
them because I've been nothing but happy
with his products since he's since he's
been a director now we we just climbed
through all of cainhurst castle and you
could see how gorgeous this is
as we get on to the rooftops we're just
going to do a little bit of patented
from software platforming which is one
of the things that I really still love
about this game it's simple but like the
platforming if you make if you make the
wrong move you pretty much die which is
kind of like reality it makes a lot of
sense and I love when you understand the
path thing and you and you understand
where you're going how you can speed it
up and make it look really cool we're
gonna eat Abby's blood pellet trick our
weapon through the loading screen and go
fight Martha ladarius this guy is no
joke as well
we're gonna hit him with a series of two
attacks in first phase well - if we can
hit too you can see that he is casting
arcane magic at us and we cannot get hit
by that we also have to be very careful
that he doesn't do that attack he just
did I was able to hit him out of it
thankfully this is an AOE we have to
backstab him here and we did we get the
visceral now this is Phase two right
here
his attacks will be much stronger much
more eclectic wow I missed the parry on
that my mistake I was a little bit too
quick a little bit too antsy let's try
to bait him now we couldn't get him to
do the second one there
oh my pellet ran out no big deal no big
deal
let's go in swoop for a couple he is so
aggressive in phase two you really have
to be careful swipe them on the backside
I went for one extra attack I probably
didn't need to just a little bit late
let's go for this and we hate them out
of the sky that's how you kill a boss
let's take the lamp and get home
hit me with some more donations
absolutely we've got $13 from Benny
Louise towards covet relief efforts and
he says when I grow up I wish to be Zeus
in blood-borne and we got $100 from
kaiju syndrome towards Kovac relief
efforts thank you so much and then for
black lives matter we've got $25 for
math you eaten and then $20 from Paul
hand I'm just going to double check Tito
oh we're at 9000 287 it looks like for
black lives matter and then 7640 for
towards covered relief efforts thank you
so much that everyone there has donated
it's super appreciated both donation
links are at the bottom of your screens
and you can also find them in chat and
on gamespot website if you need to yeah
thank you so much that is unbelievable
to me that we've been able to raise that
amount of money so quickly you guys are
being awesome I did forget to do one
thing on my my trip up good thing I
remembered too because if I had it we
wouldn't have been able to trigger the
final boss later on so what we got to do
is go back to well we had to get wait we
got to go to an area called the
abandoned workshop and we got to pick up
an umbilical cord from there I mentioned
that I needed three we only have gotten
two so far so one of them that we've
gotten has been from wet-nurse or from
mer go more specifically mer goes
wet-nurse and the other was from that
lady on the table so right through this
door is basically a carbon copy of the
hunter's dream but in reality the
hunter's dream is a copy
you bend an old workshop you notice the
difference we get a nice look at the
Blood Moon off in the background right
there and we're gonna take this
umbilical cord and immediately destroy
it because it has no business being in
this world and I also don't want to
forget light this lamp and we're going
to head back now we get to go and do the
DLC I failed the first Ludwig fight but
this time we'll try to be a little bit
better a little bit faster you need to
drink some water hold on let's go up the
left side right here to the hunter's
gravestone and work to the nightmare
Church now Ludwig is one of those fights
that he's really difficult but he's even
more difficult on like challenges like
blood level 4 or new game+ 6 because his
health pool is so much higher than on
regular new game I'm honestly I feel on
regular new game he doesn't have enough
health kind of like pontiff Sullivan
from Dark Souls 3 you just can parry
Sullivan a couple times and then his
phase starts and he sort of stands still
and you can kill him kind of quickly but
if you do the soul level one challenge
pontiff is no joke and it's kind of the
same with what Rick I thought that I was
good at the game years ago before I did
blood level 4 for the first time and I I
got on to Ludwig and man it took I
didn't even finish the fight that day
which had never happened to me before
that's how hard he was for me
let's go to the left over here so it
doesn't fight my head off just missed
that hit we're gonna go under here I'm
in a bad spot
okay I was able to actually get out of
that that was a terrible spot to be in
we got the head shot let's get the
visceral right to his face or one of his
faces I should say go for a jump oh but
we just missed oh my god he tried to
kill me he almost did alright he's
giving me the fight here BAM wait not
enough damage a kill shot no way are you
kidding me
my beast blood pellet ran out
unbelievable but there it is phase two
of the fight he's got a big giant
moonlight blade sword and he's not
afraid to use it
double back step and we're just right
outside his range this is one of my
favorite parts of the game right here
sit back and enjoy
he almost killed me let's take that
visceral let's make the music louder
we're just gonna we're just gonna let
him do his thing for a minute here
[Music]
[Music]
and he's done
it's worth turning the music up for that
fight it really is it's just such a good
one I was gonna say the absolute flex
yeah I got chills watching that so I'm
sure I'm glad you guys liked it I I i
absolutely adore that fight and like I
said when I when I learned I always
thought he was a Trent like kind of too
easy because I was a speed runner and
only speedrunning him a new game he made
me he forced me to respect him and that
that's what I love about him I'll never
trash him again because that boss is
absolutely no joke and it's just
gorgeous
it is absolutely gorgeous but right
after him we have the research Hall
which might be one of the most scary
places in the game if you think about
what's going on all these patients have
been experimented on with various
different versions of blood and and
chemicals to alter their form and the
doctors that are taking care of them
don't seem to care about them one bit
and it's if you just think about that
the people pleading out and screaming
here it's absolutely it's just atrocious
and horrific really and blood-borne is a
horror game it might might not be like
the jump-scare Michael Myers or Alien
Resurrection kind of game but what goes
on in this game is is the definition of
horror
it is horrible if this was reality it
would be absolutely terrifying
got any more donations before the the
next boss we do we have $10 towards Ovid
relief effort from Dan because there's
thanks GameSpot for all you guys do and
thank you Asus for the run Dan Beck also
donate $10 towards black lives matter
thank you so much then for the double
donation and then Michael Hawley has
donated $100 towards black lives matter
thank you so much for all the donations
where
nk4 black lives matter we are currently
at nine thousand three hundred ninety
three and then seven thousand six
hundred and fifty four for coded relief
efforts every penny every dollar goes
directly towards both causes and will be
massively helpful so thank you please
donate if you can and share yukon you
guys are absolutely killing it i keep
saying that but it keeps being true
thank you so much we have living
failures coming up which these are the
product of all the experiments that have
gone on in the research all and quite
frankly the experiment failed because
this is not what they were looking for
so all those people basically got tested
on for absolutely nothing we got a quick
backstab on the guy go for another
charge
avoid that you do not want to get hit by
it now the key to this fight is going to
be killing them before they kill us
which seems simple but the truth is
there's a lot there's a lot of potential
for them to spawn too many and if you
have three or four of them attacking you
at the same time like you're starting to
see here it becomes a terrible terribly
difficult fight if I pretty much two
shots this entire fight if I get hit I
cannot get hit again maybe if I'm lucky
if I don't take any counter hit damage
it'll be three but these guys wallop you
they got a lot of leverage in that lanky
arm now this is one of the coolest
things in the game about I'm actually
just going to stand still and let you
guys appreciate it for a second
and then go right behind grab the booty
and hit a visceral nearly two-thirds
done I'm gonna go to the single instead
of the grouping of two they're following
me though we've got to be careful got to
be careful do not want to get caught
here I saw that that second one was
attacking they can't remember they can
hit me through each other they don't
have collision so I got to be very
careful when come one comes right in
from behind
[Applause]
I was gonna fully charge that backstab
but I saw the other guy coming and I
decided to leave oh man I didn't even
see that arcane magic come cry in
towards me
that's Davis when I was able to get a
double shot with both of them and got a
quick kill very nice
let's light this lamb just in case for
safety actually you know what we'll do
since I have only nine blood vials we're
gonna go and get an item we need to get
one of the the last DLC bosses Lawrence
so we'll go back to the hunters dream
get some blood vials go to the research
hall do a little short skip with an
elevator to get us quickly down to the
bottom which guesses the item we need
we'll war back and then we'll go do
Maria so hit me with a few donations
absolutely we call $40 from our very own
Ashley Oh towards Corvette relief
efforts thank you so much Ashley and
that can be a hard work in supporting
our stream and we got $10 from Eric Tay
who is a mastermind in keeping all this
beam stuff running thank you he says he
like to express his appreciation for
turning up the boss music during the
Ludwig fight and then we call one $25
donation from inigo montoya who didn't
leave a comment but I think if we go
with something like my name is Inigo
Montoya you killed my father gascoigne
prepared to die that works definitely
thank you so much to everyone donating
all right this is what I was talking
about before back to the research hall
if you notice I did send this elevator
back down as soon as I got here we're
gonna wait till the elevator goes up to
that point jump onto the statues head
roll off lock on dash
back drop down and pick up Lawrence's
skull and then we'll use a bold hunter's
mark as soon as we can find it and we're
back now we're gonna go we get we're
going back to the dream and then we're
gonna go back to lumen flower gardens
and the astral Clocktower to face lady
Maria who's according to many people one
of the best bosses in the game and
rightfully so rightfully so I I said
before that orphan of cause is my
favorite but Maria definitely is up
there she's got a lot of different
attacks she's got a blood magic she's
got fire magic and she combines them
both in a beautiful way in a beautiful
way you're gonna see that right here
now in first phase she's not gonna have
any of that blood or fire magic she's
going to do ray a power up to phase two
she's gonna get blood magic and then a
power up to Phase three and get the fire
as well and during a second and third
phase I have to be extremely careful
because she has a ton I mean a ton of
damage now watch how she moves you see
that's that burst of smoke we're gonna
mimic her and make this fight really
good we're good we're gonna use the art
of quickening through the old Hunter's
bone to look exactly like how she moves
now with Maria and with gehrman as well
they have this ability as an innate
ability it's something that's a part of
them they don't need to use the bone
they just have it unfortunately the
player character in the game is actually
relatively weak to everything else that
has been in the nightmare for a long
long time so we have to use special
tools to make up for it whereas Maria
and gehrman they've got that ability
right off the bat let's use the bone
again get some blood bullets
that's dangerous extremely dangerous you
know what I think I know how she's gonna
move and I do preempted the parry
attempt got the visceral and she's gonna
transform the face to now we're gonna
spam her as much as I can back just
outside of the range go right in we got
two attacks got a few more actually
there's the charge that I'm talking
about
gotta go behind oh just missed the booty
slap take two attacks now it's time for
Phase three a rush of blood
disgusting engorging but I'm the blood
god after all I'm dead wow I didn't I
didn't expect to get a hit there I
didn't expect to get a hit there the
fire trailed me right behind me I rolled
right into it and she got me right like
that you see how quick you see how quick
she can kill you it's no joke no joke at
all now keep in mind I did that on
purpose because I just wanted to show
off just how good of a fight she is I
didn't want anybody out there who's new
to the game thinking that I was just
gonna first try everything so you got to
die on purpose to make sure people can
still get into the game that's how I do
things so at this time we're gonna use a
beast blood pellet stagger her out of
her hyper poise and try to get her down
as quick as possible
because we do not want to die again I'll
take my blood echoes just just because
they annoy me that the the spot on the
floor is actually a pretty big
distraction for me and getting it out of
the way helps me focus on the lady who's
trying to kill me right here Wow is
hoping for some for a stagger there but
I didn't get it let's double pump the
heal I feel like a trick attack there I
can probably get I'm going to go for
three back step away
okay now we're gonna go through can we
get to we just missed we just missed the
second one it's okay I feel I know what
she's doing the same thing she's got to
look to her she's got to look to her and
if you if you played the game enough you
know when she's gonna do certain attacks
all right now it's time for the old
hunters bone Wow you see how amazing
this fight is she could just hit you so
quick and then if you dodge in the wrong
way see I dodge too far forward and the
fire trail hit me but if you dodge at
the exact right time and in the exact
right location you can punish and here's
a full charge we got to go through past
get the booty slap and we did it we're
gonna kill her with a visceral that's
how it should have been done the first
time thanks guys
for killing her we get the celestial
dial we raise it up and we get to look
at a beautiful moment in the game it's
it's just it's just a gearbox turning
but it's gorgeous
hit me with some more donations we've
got twenty dollars towards Colgate
relief efforts from born-again Souls
thank you so much
we've got 500 dollars from executive
producer James Watt and civilization
addict Chris Beaumont thank you so much
Chris Thomas Malinsky $25 Nathan Riddick
$20 every dollar goes to vital causes
you can see both of our links at the
bottom of the video or find them in care
and Italy Falls but sheis BLM to support
black lives matter and then of course -
yes - covet to support coalbed relief
efforts thank you so much to everyone
for watching and for also donating if
you can please do donate if you can't
share the screen there's been more folks
in here washing because frankly this is
an incredible run for watch now I'm
trying to guess what appear
thank you so much we're gonna we're in
the fishing hamlet right now but I'm not
gonna fight orphan of cause just yet I'm
actually gonna fight orphan of cause
last on this run he's my favorite to me
he's the true final boss of the game so
we're gonna kill Lawrence next gehrman
moon presents and then I'm gonna show
you guys a little bit of a trick to to
not end the game and go back and do
whatever you want
so let's light this lamp get back to the
dream and go fight Lawrence this is this
is the best part of the game I really do
feel like it the DLC in this game is
unparalleled there's five bosses a few
different areas but it's just it's such
high quality the entire time it's it's
often the the price of blood-borne is
$20 and the price of the DLC is $20 and
you get so much more content in the main
game but the DLC is still worth it
because of quality that the bosses are
amazing the lore is amazing you get so
many different weapons so many different
hunter's tools the dialogue the level
design its it's just all gorgeous I love
it to death and you you might say that
I'm biased because of the amount of
hours that I put in and you're right but
it doesn't make it any less true
oh my god dude I almost got killed right
there that guy that guy rarely hits you
in the back they've got they've got like
a sprint forward attack much like
quickening I was not expecting that this
door is gonna open automatically for us
and an octopus big guy or an octopus
face whatever you want to call him is
gonna try to stop us he does have an
attack that could kill us but he didn't
give it to us there thankfully all right
this boss has a lot of health I'm gonna
need a focus up here a lot of health
we're gonna go in we're gonna try to hit
his left leg a few times he's going for
a grab so I'm getting out of it getting
out of there go for the same thing he if
he hits me at all you're gonna see me
heal and the reason for that is he does
insane damage two shots are gonna kill
me I might die here I'm kidding I would
never die there that's too early in the
fight I made a couple mistakes though
already let's buckle up and get it
there we got our first stagger so now we
can start focusing on the other side
he's gonna go up I'm gonna go forward he
does tagged me with an AoE but I can
still get two hits while he back swipes
I will full heal he's gonna back up
that's a dangerous attack we got to get
under the arm there
he's already flopping okay this is
dangerous I will heal if you are
fighting Loras that triple swipe attack
you have to learn how to dodge that
because if you're anywhere close to him
he will spam that like it's no tomorrow
oh I was going for the headshot I wanted
the visceral we'll have to try that one
more time here if he gives me that
attack again we'll try it so this is the
attack that I'm talking about learn the
timing for that that will make the fight
go a lot smoother for you trust me we're
gonna let him go while I heal it up I've
already used nine blood vials this
hasn't been a very good fight I've been
very peachy he's doing this a move he
hit me with fire from way too far that's
that's a shame that's a shame
it's our pad you know what let's start
attacking him I'm trying to get the head
there I'm trying it's hard to get the
head wow that's a lot of damage
that's just dangerous guys I might die
here whoo okay oh that's a that's a grab
I can't I can't maybe here headshot
give me the stagger let's go it took a
few times but I finally got it just when
the Beast blood pellet runs out - let's
take a hit he's probably gonna transform
any moment now always giving me a few
hits there he's gonna flop over now I
call this guy Lieutenant Dan why because
at the start of the movie he has legs
but by the end of it he doesn't seem to
have any legs
he's also kind of ornery like Lieutenant
Dan to get under that get under that I
cannot get hit here if I get hit I will
get trapped I will die
under that was actually a little bit too
early I have to be careful there
he hasn't done any of the super powerful
attacks yet which means he's probably
gonna start doing them any moment he
does have attacks that can one-shot me
you know what he's being nice I'm gonna
allow him to be nice I'm not gonna spam
attacks though that was dangerous
got a stick to the side do not get
caught in the lava and I'm just noticing
now that might be oh god no you know
what I thought about dying for
entertainment purposes there but then I
thought better of it we kill them
instead
what a great boss fight' good yes that
guy's technically a reskin remember a
cleric be said that the first boss of
the game but to me that this is a reskin
done right because all the particle
effects and the fire effects and the the
extra two phases that you get with him
it just he actually has the most
combinations of any boss fight in the
game he's got about fifty different
variations in his attack sequencing
which to me is just phenomenal so if
you're gonna do a reskin that's that's
the model of what you're gonna do and
it's the only boss reskin in the game as
well now I did say that I was going to
kill gehrman and Moon presents before
orphan of cos so let's go and do that
notice biryeo blade versus biryeo blade
this is gehrman's weapon he gives us the
helicopter attack to start off which is
a rare attack very hard to avoid we're
gonna parry that and take the visceral
there I'm gonna dash forward and hit him
with a trick knocked him out of the
helicopter
that's hyper poised though you know what
I want to be able to dodge that I use
the beast blood pellet I can't use the
old Hunter's bone I made a mistake
doesn't matter we'll switch to our gun
and get a parry go through take a trick
stagger him out
oh he's bringing out the shotgun now if
you notice that shotgun has a spray
pattern to it he also has another
ability he's got a slug shot which will
actually if it hits you will power you
and he could take a visceral from that
and he doesn't have to have a proper
timing at all he just needs to hit you
that's how strong it is these blood
pellet has run out
he's got moon power now you see that
aura coming from him
he's summing the power from the moon and
now he cannot cannot be staggered at all
now we have the old hunters bone he's
summoning up some more moon power but we
gotta back out of here because this is a
huge AOE don't want to get touched there
run through he tried shooting me oh
that's a kill shot you don't want to get
hit by that there's the slug right there
you could tell by how he moves what kind
of shot you're gonna get we're gonna
take that parry if he's gonna give it to
me
take the visceral if he's gonna give it
to me we're gonna go forward hit him
with a trick slice them in half use some
blood billets heal ourselves up use the
old Hunter's bone let's watch this
cutscene
we've got a little bit of extra time
that's one of the most beautiful scenes
as grotesque as it is and now she's
gonna give us strawberries we don't want
strawberries though we want blood
she's gonna shake her noodle hair at me
because she's angry she's got a little
flair to herself oh and she hits me with
the noodles so let's go so bring some
face shots I want to be at full health
let's roll that I want to get the
stagger on her I wanna its new game+ six
though it might be kind of difficult
slid right under the arm there I pretty
sure that connected as a head attack we
just need a few more and we can get it
we got the arm and we got the head now
let's see if we get the visceral of
course we get the visceral I'll go for a
full charge to the other arm didn't get
the stagger there so she takes me down
to 1 HP we got to heal up let's see what
she does she smacks me in the face what
is she doing oh she's going for an
overhead well that's nothing for me the
Beast is dead
so let's war back so if you use a bold
hunter's mark at the exact right moment
you can beat the final boss of the game
but still go around in the game wherever
you want it's not until you cross the
threshold of the the final area again
until the doll knocks you over the head
with a cinder block knocking you out and
then she turns you into a giant slug
we'll get there later on but before we
need to fight orphan of cos this is by
far my favorite boss in all of video
games hit me with a few more donations
we're gonna do a skip and we're gonna
quit out right here so we got some time
Benny Lewis donated again sixteen
dollars and said lady Maria gives us a
hug can't wait for off enough cause
Alphonse for today but good luck with
the donation that's thank you so much
bye Lewis that means a lot that was for
kovat relief efforts and info covered
relief efforts Vincent TV $85 a twenty
five dollars and a donation in the honor
of the best blood-borne streamer ever
the blood god Zeus thanks for the
streams and motivation you bring every
day
thank you brother Kieran O'Brien twenty
dollars often of course made me cry and
then for black lives matter we have
fifty dollars from Emma rage and then
fifty dollars from Charlotte Seymour and
we have past I believe let me just
double check if we passed the 10k
milestone on black lives matter
donations we're at ten thousand six
hundred and twenty three and then 7775
for corbett relief efforts thank you to
everyone that is watching and is
donating and thank you to everyone that
is chatting away in alongside the play
and making it fun for everyone who's new
and who is the game I'm stuck I failed
the skip it's okay though I haven't
failed that skip in a long time we got
to do it again yeah enough nothing to
see here
just just break in the game and the game
is breaking me in the town of it that's
how it works
bubble yep we'll try it again we'll try
it again do you have any more donations
or is that where you have any question I
will tell you I will put this to you you
mentioned this briefly earlier but the
frequency of rumors comes along around
blood-borne returning as on PC on PS 5
it's been another one today which is
blob on remaster coming to PC and ps4
I've soon developed by Q Locke and blue
point games will have better textures
and models but loading times and more
quality of life improvements 60 FPS 4k
ultra wide support and coming to steam
what do you think of that I think that
I've I've heard about these rumors every
single day of my life for the past four
years and I I basically at this point
just need them to be true so people stop
asking me about them I mean it every
single day 100 times a day that's all I
hear and I look I love blood-borne I'm
gonna I know why people ask me but it's
just the it's just over and over again
please be making it please so you just
end my nightmare because I can't deal
with it anymore I just need it to be
true I think we all agree all right he
doesn't give me the jump he goes for the
swipe I'm gonna hit him back to back
with a couple swipes myself stagger him
and hit him again we're gonna back off
to the side there he almost swiped me
but I wasn't out like that
okay maybe I was going to let it happen
he did hit me a couple times there and
we're healing right in his face just
like I told you I would I'm not gonna
back away from a fight I'm just gonna
knuckle down and get through it even if
I get hit let's see can I get a full
charge backstab here he backs away what
a legend you see this guy
there's my working bait right there you
use a blood vial you get him to jump
over you you get the visceral and you're
ready to go
one more booty slap pull him will smack
me into oblivion right there another
swipe through quick attack I got the
sagger if I
you
you
[Music]
I got to get my discord back on here
holy hell
I'm very yeah my colors are all out of
whack
you
you
Jesus that is a little bit disappointing
huh
just at the final fight hold on I gotta
get my discord is refusing to load right
now
you
you
guys I'm so sorry my power literally
just cut out you do not need to
apologize that was blood bone just being
blood-borne they didn't want me to run
the Dollywood it was like often of
causes gang stomped this is supposed to
be a hardest boss what we do Miyazaki
over there was a big red button you
think it was a probably what Miyazaki
has been ruining my life for years man
the moment before it happened I was like
it's interesting Miyazaki has it
attempted to suffer this at all right
now and then as oh wait so you jinxed it
I think I'm very sorry that's watching
and at the same time we had someone just
donate and it was like it was $20 from
Jones mark or towards Cove it relief and
he said fear the old blood which is
another woman s another ominous sign
that something was about to happen but I
shouldn't be surprised this is blah pawn
after all and and honestly blood-borne
has a history of like canceling my
streams are gonna do so not even the
world's first no hit run that I got it
literally the game crashed during that
run like blood-borne blood-borne is
constantly just trying to ruin my life I
think I think if anything this is
consistent with what happens to you what
blood-borne does to people and also I
think a lot of people in chat are
probably just happy that you're back and
we get to what you play a bit more so no
harm no foul there as far as we're
concerned just give me I got a reset the
sound here give me one second no worries
in the meantime I'll just let people
know that we are raising money games for
as play for all is happening for
multiple weeks we're going throughout
June into July and we're gonna be
raising money for Kobe relief efforts
you can see the bitly link at the bottom
there bit dot ly for the GS - Co vid and
we're also raising money for black lives
matter and important charitable cause
much needed right now and you can donate
at bit door ly for /gs b - BLM any and
all you can give is super appreciate if
you can spread the word about it that
that would be amazing - a lot of people
have done it at that time and and kind
of skills as you can see Zeus is doing
to put in on these charity streams so
please do tune in it didn't even
I just put me back as if I hadn't even
gone here anyway what just happened at
the nightmare swirls and turns on ending
indeed oh we got to jump off and a
visceral attack right to start things
off I'm gonna destroy this guy for what
he's done to this stream I'm not having
this oh the quick attack no way he does
not do oh my bad that combo right there
is basically instant death unless you
realize what's happening get out all
right if you're gonna stand still I'm
going to move you oh I might be dead
over my head into a visceral let's go
this fight is going well let's take a
heal action maybe he'll transform he
doesn't transform now let's see if he
does it I am the master orphan Bader
I paid orphan better than anybody else
one more
oh he hit me off the top of the head no
way second phase we got him down this
world will it kill not quite we've got
more work to do but now it's over
easy
I just want to play this cutscene
because I love it
we got to kill the final nightmare
anyway this is my favorite cutscene in
the whole game beautiful
look at those booty shorts I pants or
whatever they are underneath oh the
bottomless curse a bottomless sea
accepting of all that is and can be
I love a man I love it only one thing
left to do and this run is over all the
bosses have been defeated we just got to
get hit with a cinder block from the
doll and get turned into a giant baby
slug and we're done it's been a lot of
fun guys thank you so much
we've got a few final donations Benny
Lewis came back and said we must finish
this last time $15 a day one cents mean
cat $10 my boomer on it loves watching
you also wants to donate she doesn't
know how but here I am to donate for her
yeah that was for covin relief Jay Clark
$15 for BLM Michael Lea $10 for black I
was mayor grace Polivka $10 black labs
my tailor costs great name $50 Lance
IKEA $25 thank you everyone who has done
it during the stream it means the world
to all of us and you're all contributing
to two important causes thank you so
much thank you everyone for donating
from me thanks for watch and I'm hey
Zeus here's toast I hope you guys
enjoyed this run I'm glad that I didn't
do a full speed run and I could show you
the game with a really cool weapon a
really cool weapon in max new game I
hope you guys liked it thank you so much
absolutely for happen thank you so much
there's for coming on the show
of the game being played at its highest
and you've made a few people more
interested in the game you've raised a
lot of money your skills are impressive
and it is a reason why you called the
blood Guard and I'm glad that we were
able to show the world today yeah that
was awesome no thank you
all right that's the end of our stream
for today come back tomorrow for more
we're gonna have tomorrow for days
come back for more and yeah donate to
black last night and call the relief
efforts if you can take everyone thanks
so much have a great day everyone
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]